CARTER MORGAN: We've secured
our dependency chain.
We've made sure
our code is secure.
Add a CAT to that.
It must be secure at
this point, right?
Wrong.
It's time to look at
protecting our developers
from devious phishing attacks.
No matter how secure your
code bases from the outside,
if someone manages to get
into one of your devs' account
with a good phishing
attack, then all
of those previous protections?
Useless.
A typical login flow
looks something like this.
You present your
login to the server.
Then you're in.
But, oh no, someone
was actually giving you
a very clever phishing
page, and you've
given them your credentials.
Now they can do anything you
could have done, like modify
source code, install malware,
or even send emails with too
many emojis to your whole team.
What about a one-time password
generated by your phone?
Unfortunately, that doesn't
always prevent phishing,
because a phisher
can just take that,
pass it forward with
your credentials,
and now they're logging in
as you, just as successfully.
There has got to be a better
way to secure the people who
access your system, and that's
where security keys come in.
They can be used as
B keys, or Bluetooth,
or you can even use your
Android phone as one.
And these serve as a much
stronger second factor
to make your login secure.
So let's see how
security keys would
have stopped that previous
phishing attempt in its tracks.
Instead of being
complete after you've
given a login name
and a password,
the server replies
with a challenge,
because it knows that
you registered a security
key on your account already.
Your security key
accepts that challenge,
verifies that it does
recognize the domain name,
and uses its hidden
private key to sign it.
This means a phishing domain,
even a very cleverly disguised
one with a URL that looks
almost exactly the same,
except for that
weird ASCII character
it's using this not really
an O but it looks like an O?
Yeah, that won't work.
The key won't sign the challenge
and return it to the domain
if it isn't exactly
what it was set up with.
If everything does check
out, your security key
accepts the challenge, verifies
that it recognizes the domain
name, and uses its hidden
private key to sign it.
Finally, the server
uses the public key
to verify the
signature, and it knows
you have the same physical
key that you had before.
Now, this is strong
authentication that's
very resistant to phishing.
Preventing phishing is
just as easy as that.
Once you set these
keys up and change
the 2-step authentication
to only use security keys
in the Google Admin
UI, then the next time
a developer logs on after
they enter their password,
they'll be asked to
touch their security key.
Plug that in, give it
a tap, now you're in.
That's the end of this
little security journey.
Thank you for going
along this ride with me.
I'm Carter Morgan, and you?
You are now a certified expert
in all things app security.
Or maybe not.
What do you think?
Leave your response
in the comments below.
And don't forget, if you want
to see more great Google Cloud
content like this, please like
and subscribe to the page.
[MUSIC PLAYING]